to some degree we are already a sidewall
over time I think we'll probably see a
closer merger of biological intelligence
and digital intelligence
what's that believe nation it's Evan my
one word is believe and I believe in you
I believe you have Michael Jordan level
talent at something and I want you to
find it embrace it and use it to make a
difference so to help you on your
journey today we're going to talk about
how humans will become cyborgs and Elon
Musk solution to the AI problem also if
you want to know what Elon Musk and
other successful entrepreneurs have to
say about building unstoppable
confidence check out my 250 for
confidence series where every day for
the next 254 days I will send you a
short 30 second to 5 minute video for
free to help you build your confidence
check out the link in the description
below I think I feel feel fair quite
strongly so it's not as though I just
have the absence of fear I've I feel it
quite strongly but there are times when
something is important enough you
believe in it enough that you do you do
it in spite of the fear I think
ultimately we will have to have some
kind of universal basic income I don't
think we can have a choice Universal
Music Inc universal basic income I think
it's gonna be necessary
so it's mean that unemployed people will
be paid across the globe yeah because
there is no job machine robot is taking
over there will be fewer and fewer jobs
that a robot cannot do better but that's
simply the that I don't want to be clear
these these are not things that I think
that I wish would happen these are
things simply things that I think
probably will happen and since in if if
my assessment is correct and they
probably will happen then we need to say
what are we gonna do about it and I
think some kind of a universal basic
income is going to be necessary now the
output the output of goods and services
will be extremely high so with
automation they will they will come
abundance
there will be almost everything will get
very cheap the is so it's I think the
biggest I think we'll just end up doing
a universal basic income it's gonna be
necessary the harder challenge much
harder challenge is how do people then
have meaning like a lot of people they
derive the meaning from their employment
so if you don't have if you're not
needed if there's not a need for your
labour how do you what's the meaning if
you have meaning if you feel useless
these are much that's a much harder
problem to deal with and then how do we
ensure that the future is going to be
the future that we want that we so like
no I mean I do think that there's a
potential path here which is and we're
really getting into a science fiction or
create you know sort of advanced science
stuff but having some sort of merger
with biological intelligence and machine
intelligence just to some degree we are
already a cyborg you think like you
think of like the digital tools that you
have your phone your computer the
applications that you have like the fact
that I was mentioning earlier you can
ask a question and instantly get an
answer from Google you know from other
things and and so you already have a
digital tertiary tertiary layer I say to
Sheree because you can think of the
limbic system kind of the the animal
brain or the primal brain and then the
court cortex kind of the thinking
planning part of the brain and then your
digital self as a third layer the so you
already have that and anything if
somebody dies their digital ghost is
still around there all of their emails
and the picture
that they posted in the social media
vessel lives even if they physically if
they died so over time I think we'll
probably see a closer merger of
biological intelligence and digital
intelligence and it's mostly about the
the bandwidth the speed of the
connection between your brain and your
digital the digital extension of
yourself particularly output like when
and and output if anything is getting
worse you know we we used to have like
keyboards that would use a lot now we do
most of our input through our thumbs on
a phone and this is very slow a computer
can communicate at a trillion bits per
second but your thumb can maybe do under
ten bits per second or hundred if you
being generous so some high bandwidth
interface to the brain I think will be
something that helps achieve a symbiosis
and between human and machine
intelligence and maybe souls the control
problem and the usefulness problem going
back to the AI situation this is quite
important kind of one debate like that
if you assume any rate of advancement in
AI we will be left behind by a lot and
so then we could be in like you know
benign but the venom even the benign
situation if you have some you know if
you have ultra intelligent AI we would
be you know so that was so far below
them in intelligence that it would be
would be like you know a pet is like a
bat I can't it's like a cat you like
that yeah we like the house cat right
and yeah so that's something of the
world you know No so that's seen the
movie it could be it could be could be
the you know so that but that honestly
other whatever you the Pennine scenario
and so housecat is okay I mean I don't
love the idea of being a house good okay
but but that what's the solution yeah so
I think the I think I think it I think
it's to essentially I think one of the
solutions the solution that it seems may
be the best one is to have an AI layer
if you think of like you've got your
limbic system your cortex and then a
digital layer a sort of a third layer
above the cortex that could work work
well and symbiotically with with you I
mean just as your cortex works um but
somatically with the olympic system your
did sort of a third digital layer could
work symbiotically with the rest this is
something that's even surgically
inserted or bred to the species or what
the fundamental imitation is
input/output so we already have we're
already a cyborg it's just that you have
a digital version of yourself a partial
version of yourself online in the form
of your emails and your social media and
all the things that you do and and you
have basically superpowers in that with
your computer in your phone and and the
applications that are there you have
more power than the president I states
had twenty years ago that you can answer
any question you can video conference
with anyone anywhere you can send a
message to millions of people instantly
effectively merging in a symbiotic way
with digital intelligence revolves
around eliminating the i/o constraint so
it's some sort of direct cortical
interface and you called it a neural
layer of neural lace yeah it's totally
not Google glass right no I'm talking
about something where they know I mean
it would be I mean I mean there are a
few ways to approach this but some sort
of interface directly with your cortical
neurons particularly but doesn't my
surgical insertion not necessarily you
could go through the veins and arteries
because that that provides a complete
roadway to all of your neurons your
neurons are very heavy users of energy
so they need high blood flow so you
automatically with your veins and
arteries have a road network to your
neurons
still some kind of surgery right yes but
you could insert something you know
basically you know into the jugular and
and have I get some a Cobb but it sounds
really easy and it doesn't involve it
doesn't involve you know like chopping
or just get your skull or anything like
that
okay thank you guys so much for watching
I hope you enjoyed I'd love to know what
are your thoughts about humans becoming
cyborgs and the solution to the AI
problem please let me know leave your
thoughts in the comments below thank you
guys so much for watching I believe in
you I hope you continue to believe in
yourself and whatever your one word is
much love I'll see you soon
altruistic world domination honey Empire
right I'm grateful I understand why I'm
here I think because I am so open I
wanted to think and see it's a bloody
brief life all of you have the potential
for enormous success if you want to know
what Gary v-d-j Khalid Oprah and others
know about empire building that most
people miss check out the link in the
description for a free bonus video